[Musique]
j'accueille ce matin damien abad vous
êtes député de l'ain et président du
groupe l'est républicain à l'assemblée
nationale bonjour damien abad bonjour
alors nous sommes ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour couvrir plusieurs sujets
d'actualité et on va commencer par
l'actualité économique car le
constructeur automobile renault pourrait
fermer quatre usines en france et une
information du canard enchaîné
qu'est ce que l'état doit faire pour
éviter cela et bien il faut relancer la
machine économique
très clairement on voit bien aujourd'hui
que le confinement aura des conséquences
économiques majeures j'ai entendu le
chiffre de 76 % de baisse de ventes du
secteur automobile
aujourd'hui au niveau européen et donc
ce que l'on peut constater très
clairement c'est qu'il va y avoir des
difficultés économiques et notamment à
la rentrée et des risques de plans
sociaux
donc l'état doit mot être mobilisés pour
soutenir et investir stratégiquement
dans les filières essentiels comme
l'automobile comme l'aéronautique comme
ces secteurs clés en france qui sont
pourvoyeurs d'emplois les créateurs de
richesses alors précisément sur ce plan
social à renault il pourrait intervenir
avant la rentrée il ya une certaine
urgence je rappelle que l'état est
actionnaire à 15% au capital de renault
est ce que l'état doit dire aux
constructeurs eh bien il faut attendre
avant de licencier avant de réaliser ce
plan social
il faut en tout cas qu'une discussion se
fasse entre partenaires et notamment
entre l'état et le constructeur
je pense qu'aujourd'hui avoir un plan
social avec 3600 emplois menacés
ce n'est pas rien et donc c'est pas une
décision qui peut se prendre comme cela
à la légère je crois qu'aujourd'hui faut
pas précipiter les choses
on démarre à peine le déconfinement et
donc il faut pouvoir engager cette
reprise économique c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que chez les républicains nous
demandons à ce que le projet de relance
il se fasse pas en septembre c'est trop
tard au mois de septembre
il faut le faire dès l'été parce que
c'est ce qui va permettre d'enclencher
la machine économique
et malheureusement l'actualité nous le
montre que c'est indispensable d'agir
dès maintenant notamment pour les
grandes entreprises notamment pour les
constructeurs automobiles parce qu'on
sait que la firme automobile est
fortement touchée elle est impactée elle
va être impactée sur la durée mais on ne
peut pas se satisfaire de plans sociaux
qui vont tomber les uns après les autres
sans discussion sans négociation et sans
perspective d'avenir
mais est-ce que la relance économique ça
suffit est ce que dans le cadre nous
l'état ne doit pas gelé ces
licenciements tout simplement vous savez
il ya ensuite une loi économique qui
fait que vous pouvez essayer de geler
tous les sentiments qu'il faut et bien
c'est impossible
je dis toujours que tant que les
politiques monteront sur les faux de
florange c'est qu'on n'aura pas compris
qu'elle est finalement l'impact
économique de tout ça moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'on puisse dans
l'anticipation qu'on puisse réfléchir
par exemple à des mécanismes
d'annulation de charges sociales qu'on
puisse définir ensemble des exonérations
éventuellement fiscal qu'on puisse fuir
surtout relancer d'investissements
publics et des années dans les
investissements stratégiques peut-être
qu'il faut un plan plus important qui
permettra c'est ça la relance c'est
qu'aujourd'hui combler un manque de
demande qu'il y a du fait de la crise
économique majeure et donc l'état il
doit se substituer parfois mais on le
sait je crois pas que ce soit ça des
mécanismes de gel de licenciement qui
permettront de répondre à ces
questionnements il faut rentrer dans la
négociation et soutenir nos partenaires
et soutenir nos constructeurs en france
mais aussi bien sûr en exportations à
l'étranger
alors vous le disais il ya un enjeu pour
relancer l'économie du pays il va y
avoir un débat sur le temps de travail
des français
est-ce qu'il faut mettre fin au moins
temporairement à la règle des 35 heures
ce que je peux vous dire en tout cas
c'est que moi je préfère qu'on augmente
le travail plutôt qu'on licencie les
gens je pense aussi qu'il faut non pas
une règle un cadre national
mais je pense qu'il faut donner de la
souplesse au niveau des entreprises dont
moi je souhaite qu'on ait des accords
d'entreprise que là où c'est nécessaire
parce qu'il ya des secteurs où ce sera
nécessaire parce que les secteurs où il
y aura une mobilisation de l'activité
notamment cet été quand vous vendez des
tables de jardin quand vous vendez des
choses qui sont très saisonnière il
faudra cette activité intense et donc il
faut que la loi le permettent permettent
d'aller plus loin que les 35 heures mais
je mets une condition à ça c'est que le
travail est plus doit forcément
entraîner le gagner plus il est hors de
question de passer par exemple de 35 à
37 en étant payées 35
et donc ça c'est un point important et
deuxièmement il faut pas que ce soit
général pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
secteurs qui eux vont connaître par
contre l'activité partielle je suis pas
sûr aujourd'hui que demain que dans les
cafés dans les restaurants il faille
travailler plus parce que la réalité
cdja flore déjà trouvé du travail pour
l'ensemble des salariés
donc il faut du pragmatisme du cas par
cas est donné ce cas
très souple donc vous proposer un
travailler plus pour gagner plus c'est à
dire des heures supplémentaires qui
seraient encore plus défiscalisées qui
sont déjà bien 10 fiscalisés notamment
sur la partie de charges sociales on
pourrait aller un peu plus loin mais
surtout permettre ces heures
supplémentaires permettent cette
intensification du temps de travail
cette modulation et au delà des heures
supplémentaires je souhaite aussi qu'on
a un cadre qui permette l'annualisation
du temps de travail qu'on puisse
peut-être certaines semaines travailler
davantage que 35 heures et inversement
d'autres revenir à 35 heures c'est cette
annualisation qui est nécessaire il ça
ça ne peut pas si on le fait dans un
cadre national on le sait on sera dans
un système de blocage
donc nous devons le faire entreprise par
entreprise secteur par secteur
alors damien abad on va parler d'une
autre actualité importante elle concerne
les élections municipales et
l'organisation du second tour du scrutin
le conseil scientifique n'est pas opposé
à organiser ce scrutin au mois de juin
mais en tout cas il recommande des
mesures sanitaires très strictes avec
par exemple et bien la modification de
des règles d'organisation de la campagne
un scrutin qui serait vraiment sécurisé
au niveau sanitaire
et puis le conseil scientifique demande
également une nouvelle évaluation dans
quinze jours compte tenu de l'extrême
prudence quand même de cet avis du
conseil scientifique est ce que selon
vous il faut organiser les élections
municipales en juin
je suis aussi très prudent parce que je
crois que l'opération électorale en en
elle même elle peut être organisé mais
c'est tout ce qu'il ya autour
et notamment c'est la question de la
campagne et qui est posée en tant que
tel je pense que ça doit être un choix
sanitaire est uniquement un show
sanitaire et que donc il faut que les
choses soient claires soient les
conditions sanitaires sont réunies et
alors nous pouvons obtenir ce second
tour et est le gouvernement doit en
décider ainsi soit ces conditions d'un
site sanitaires là ne sont pas réunies
on considère qu'il ya des risques qui
sont trop importants et alors il ne
faudra pas hésiter à reporter ce second
tour mais je crois vraiment aidé ainsi
sur ça je pense que ça doit être un
choix sanitaires avant même d'être un
choix politique
je voudrais simplement rajouté un point
c'est que il ya aussi comme un enjeu
économique
on le sait aujourd'hui à beaucoup de
communes beaucoup d'intercommunalité qui
ne sont pas installés et c'est pas sans
conséquence je sais que les français ne
sont pas intéressés par les élections
que ce n'est pas leur problème et j'en
conviens parfaitement
je dis simplement il ya juste un petit
sujet c'est l'investissement public 75%
des investissements publics vient de nos
collectivités locales et laisser des
communes des intercommunalités en
jachère sans installation et met une
démocratie locale entre parenthèses ce
n'est pas sans conséquences y compris
dans la relance économique
donc pour vous il faut attendre deux
semaines et le l'avis définitif du
conseil scientifique
il faut que le gouvernement prenne
décision aujourd'hui il y aura une
consultation des chefs de partis à
matignon je pense qu'à l'issue de cette
consultation il faut qu'une orientation
soit clair que l'on est un rendez-vous
d'étape oui parce que vous savez moi
j'ai dit je refuserai de voter les yeux
bandés d'ailleurs gérard larcher ont la
même opinion que nous parce que voilà
donc je pense que c'est important qu'on
ait ce rapport là mais il faut quand
même connu une augmentation parce que
moi je me mets à la place des candidates
et des candidats toutes celles et tous
ceux qui vont être candidat ils ont
quand même besoin de savoir s'ils
peuvent mener une campagne s'il va y
avoir un vote dans un mois ou pas et ça
veut pas se faire du jour au lendemain
non plus donc il faut quand même donner
une perspective est justement à propos
de cette campagne avec des mesures
sanitaires très strictes à
l'interdiction de rassemblements
l'interdiction de contacter social
finalement pendant cette campagne est ce
que cette campagne est souhaitable au
mois de juin
elle est difficile elle prendra
certainement une autre forme peut-être
qu'elle se fera davantage avec des
outils numériques nous mêmes on utilise
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus la visio c'est
sûr que les réunions publiques le
contact physique ça sera impossible y
compris dans cette campagne
donc il faut qu'il faut poser les coûts
les avantages est-ce que je suis est ce
qu'on est sûr qu'au mois de septembre on
pourra avoir une campagne avec des
réunions publiques
est ce qu'on est sûr qu'on propres
maintenant peut-être faire deux tours
parce qu'il sera nécessaire va faire
deux tours en sept ans j'en suis pas sûr
est-ce qu'il ya moins de risque et ce
qui a moins de risques à faire élections
en septembre qu'en juin je n'en suis pas
sûr non plus parce que tout dépend de
l'évolution épidémique en tant que tel
donc c'est tous ces éléments là et
toutes ces données sanitaires qu'on a
besoin d'avoir tout vous parliez des
outils numériques pour réaliser cette
campagne qui ne ressemble à aucune autre
il ya une partie des électeurs qui ne
sont pas connectés et qui n'ont pas
vraiment accès à ces outils
bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'il faudra
aussi si jamais ces élections se
tiennent lancer une grande campagne de
procuration je vois bien l'inquiétude
des personnes âgées des personnes dites
fragiles et elles doivent pouvoir voter
si elles le souhaitent doivent pouvoir
le faire donc il faut organiser et
simplifier le système de procurations
notamment pour les personnes âgées
ne pourront pas se déplacer parce que
par crainte par peur ou aussi par
précaution sanitaire il faut qu'elles
puissent avoir accès au vote donc c'est
pour ça que tout ceci ça s'organise et
aujourd'hui on est déjà quasiment un
mois du rendez-vous peut-être électorale
et donc il ya urgence sur sur cette
organisation c'est pour ça que je pense
que moi je ne souhaite pas que je suis
très prudent très réservé parce que je
crois qu'il ne faut que les choses se
passent dans les meilleures conditions
et qu'on est que tout le monde puisse
aller voter s'ils le souhaitent le faire
et aujourd'hui je vois bien que
peut-être toutes les conditions ne sont
pas réunies alors vous le disiez les
chefs de partis politiques vont être
concertée aujourd'hui hier c'était les
associations d'élus il ya eu un échange
bref d'ailleurs avec le président de la
république pourquoi le parlement ne doit
pas être ne doit pas être consultés et
décidé par un vote de cette date
électorale mais parce qu'il a déjà été
parce que le travail parlementaire a
déjà été fait parce que nous avons voté
une loi le 23 mars qui dit qu' un
rapport au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale qui sera remis le 23 mai et
que donc tout est dans la loi y compris
la date du conseil des ministres qui va
organiser les élections
donc ça ne sert à rien de revenir en
vote a bien compris la petite manoeuvre
politicienne qui consiste à ouvrir le
parapluie à mouiller les oppositions sur
quelque chose le gouvernement ne veut
pas assumer seul la décision
sauf que c'est lui seul qui a la
décision donc on pourra nous consulter
autant que l'on veut à un moment donné
celui qui tranchera en dernier ressort
ce sera le gouvernement et c'est comme
cela c'est qu'ils sont à responsabilité
donc nous on a fait notre part de jobs
on a fait notre travail parlementaire il
ya un rapport il ya une loi qui est très
précise très argumenté sur le sujet donc
maintenant c'est une affaire de parti et
c'est aux partis politiques et sur
gouvernement de régler cette question et
en même temps pour l'organisation du
scrutin du premier tour juste avant le
15 mars est bien la droite parlementaire
avait vraiment donner son avis pour
justement qu'il y ait un premier tour
pourquoi ne pas le donner sur le second
oui alors c'est un peu plus compliqué
que ça je sais qu'on nous a parfois
accusé à tort de dire d'avoir mis la
pression sur l'exécutif lot
la réalité c'est quoi moi j'étais à
cette réunion à matignon et la dernière
réunion
jamais à aucun moment le premier
ministre a posé la question aux
représentants de partis qui étaient
autour de la table en disant ce que oui
ou non vous souhaiter le maintien du
premier tour la deuxième chose c'est que
à l'époque on était reçu à matignon les
cafés les restaurants étaient ouverts
les collèges étaient ouverts et que donc
ce n'était pas de la même situation
sanitaire
donc voilà je crois que et gérard
larcher bruno retailleau christian jacob
on a tous tenu le même discours qui est
de dire ça doit être un show sanitaires
et regardons les conditions sanitaires
et c'est au gouvernement de décider
alors les maires sortants notamment les
maires des grandes villes sont un peu
moins prudents que vous ils veulent
absolument organiser ce scrutin du
second tour en jouant vous les comprenez
oui je les comprends parce que forcément
actions sur le terrain forcément ils ont
fait une campagne forcément c'est très
frustrant surtout quand vous êtes arrivé
en tête au premier tour et que vous avez
envie de transformer l'essai je
comprends tout ça pose des problèmes
démocratiques et donc j'entends bien cet
appel de terrain je le dis aussi
j'entends il faut entendre si leurs
arguments qu un argument économique il
ya besoin aujourd'hui ils ont ils ont
été élus pour certains pour d'autres ils
sont en position d'être élu ils ont
envie de faire des choses et ça se
comprend et on a un besoin de faire ces
choses là et donc on peut entendre
effectivement cet appel simplement on ne
peut pas enlever les conditions
sanitaires doivent être la priorité
absolue
on va maintenant parler d'europe puisque
la france et l'allemagne
on le sait se sont mis d'accord sur un
plan de relance européen après la crise
un plan de relance de 500 milliards
d'euros pour soutenir notamment les
régions durement frappées par cette
crise du cornet virus est ce que vous
saluer cette initiative franco allemande
oui oui c'est une bonne nouvelle oui
cette initiative franco allemande était
nécessaire et bienvenue
et oui c'est 500 milliards d'euros vont
permettre en tout cas en partie de faire
face à la crise sans précédent mais je
le dis aussi ce sont des prêts on va
passer donc à plus de 1000 milliards
d'euros de prêts européens
mais ça ne suffira pas et donc l'enjeu
qu'on devra aussi avoir en europe et qui
a commencé à être pointés par la france
et l'allemagne
c'est quoi c'est la mise en place d'une
souveraineté sanitaires dans les pays
dans les états membres
mais peut-être avec des complémentarités
entre ses états membres que la france et
l'allemagne par exemple travaillent
ensemble sur une reconstitution de
masques sur notre conception de matériel
de respirateurs je pense que ça serait
digne et utile le seul moment qu'on a vu
de solidarité entre les pays européens
c'est au moment où on a transféré les
malades d'un pays à l'autre mais si
aujourd'hui vous demandez un italien
quelle a été la solidarité européenne
ils vous répondront quasiment zéro et
donc il nous faut reconstruire cette
europe là et moi ce qui m'inquiète
au-delà des déclarations c'est que c'est
le différentiel économique et le
différentiel de résilience économique et
sanitaire entre la
c'est l'allemagne l'allemagne résiste
mieux économiquement à la demi-heure
finances publiques elle résiste mieux
sur le plan sanitaire à la préserver ces
lits de réanimation et j'ai peur que
cette différentiel la casse la dynamique
du couple franco allemand
alors emmanuel macron veut créer une
europe de la santé pour produire des
masques des tests et des médicaments
c'est une bonne solution oui mais là
encore ce sont des déclarations très
intéressante mais il faut passer au
stage d'actes et la difficulté s'il va
falloir obtenir un accord à vingt-sept
et je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse le faire
avec les vingt-sept et je pense même que
si on ne peut pas le faire avec les
vingt-sept il faudra quand même le faire
à quelques-uns et notamment avec
l'allemagne parce que c'est essentiel
sur les tests pourquoi l'allemagne a
testé trois fois quatre fois parfois
même cinq fois plus que nous ça me pose
question ça ne pose interrogation
comment se fait-il que l'allemagne en
même temps que la france dépense moins
dans sa santé l'a dépeinte dépenses de
santé dans le pipe sont inférieurs en
allemagne qu'en france
et pourtant elles ont plus de lits de
réanimation qu'en france pour comment se
fait-il qu'en france on est 35 % des
emplois hospitaliers qui ne sont pas des
emplois médicaux ni paramédicaux c'est
là où on doit regarder et analyser les
choses
et justement on va en parler de
l'hôpital public français puisque lundi
prochain le gouvernement organise une
grande concertation avec les êtres les
acteurs de la santé pour et bien
préparer un nouveau plan en faveur de
l'hôpital
est-ce que vous saluer cette initiative
du gouverneur du gouvernement qui
souhaite et bien notamment augmenter la
rémunération du personnel hospitalier
non parce que je trouve cette initiative
est injuste déséquilibrée et partial je
pense que le gouvernement s'est enfermé
encore une fois dans une logique
technocratique bureaucratiques qui fait
que ce qui était une bonne idée au
départ c'est-à-dire verser une prime aux
soignants va au final être une vraie
usine à gaz nous souhaitons nous chez
les républicains qui narre mot nisation
de cette prime entre les territoires
parce que c'est injuste de dire un
département vert mais dans un hôpital
qui avait un service kobe de plus ou qui
a été mobilisé
matin midi et soir jour et nuit de lui
dire vous vous n'aurez pas la prime
bonifiés parce que votre département et
et anvers et que le département rouge
parfois qui a 10 km ou à 20km lui verra
sa prime bonifié donc à une
harmonisation à trouver il ya un cadre a
troué et la deuxième chose je veux dire
c'est qu'au delà des primes
ce qu' il faut surtout travailler est
envisagé c'est une europe politique de
reconnaissance salariale et c'est une
politique salade qui doit aller plus
loin
moi je souhaite plutôt une loi de
programmation sanitaire qui permettrait
justement une augmentation des salaires
sur la durée et pas simplement une prime
qui vise à acheter la paix sociale de
court terme sur le temps de travail à
l'hôpital olivier ferrand parle
d'assouplissement pour certains
personnels quelle va être la proposition
des républicains sur le temps de travail
moi je les assume les 35 heures on
casser l'hôpital public en france il
faut le dire tel quel et même si ça fait
pas plaisir aux syndicats il faut le
dire parce que la réalité c'est quand
même celle là donc oui fort et organiser
le temps de travail mais ça veut dire
aussi avoir des salaires supplémentaires
franchement est ce que vous préférez une
infirmière qui travaille 35 heures et
qui est à peine plus gagnent à peine
plus que le smic ou est-ce qu'on est en
capacité d'augmenter massivement les
salaires des infirmières avec la
comprendre partie de ça c'est une
augmentation et un travail comme ça se
fait dans les autres pays européens
mais moi très clairement je choisi cette
deuxième voie et peut pas y avoir deux
en même temps parce que je vois le
gouvernement hésite et faire une espèce
de valse à trois temps pour personne se
mettre à dos la réalité s'il faut
assumer ce soit politique économique
parlons maintenant du déconfinement
puisque cela fait dix jours que les
français sont en train de se décomposer
et dans deux semaines à l'assemblée
nationale il y aura un débat sur la
fameuse application stop qu'ovide de
traçage numérique des citoyens sur la
base du volontariat pendant la période
de déconfinement quelle va être la
position des députés les républicains
sur cette application on nous allons en
discuter en réunion de groupe
l'on dit mais nous avons beaucoup de
réserve beaucoup de réserve et beaucoup
d'interrogations à double titre d'abord
la question des libertés publiques
elle ne peut pas passer par pertes et
profits ok on est en crise sanitaire ok
il faut tracer il faut faire du tracking
enfin on est quand même si un pays de
liberté on est on n'a pas la culture
d'un pays asiatique
il faut entendre cela est donc la
question des libertés ne veut pas être
éludée
deuxième chose qui m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est la question de l'efficacité
économique du modèle
je vous le dis comme je le pense je ne
crois pas un modèle basé sur l'anonymat
elle volontariat d'ailleurs je prends
juste un exemple israël quel mis en
place ce modèle là à transformer ce
modèle pas la contrainte et le caractère
obligatoire parce qu'il voyait bien que
ça montrait ses limites
sauf que je pense qu'en france nous ne
sommes pas prêts à laisser
ce modèle là et versera donc ça veut
dire quoi j'ai eu ma crainte c'est que
ça soit une application gadgets une
application qui arrive trop tard une
application qui pose des problèmes en
termes de libertés publiques et une
application dont l'efficacité coût
avantage finalement soit négative donc
nous avons beaucoup de réserves alors
dans le débat sur la gestion du
gouvernement dans cette crise sanitaire
les deux assemblées l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat vont lancer leur
commission denquête au mois de juin
le pays est encore en crise actuellement
est ce que c'était le bon moment pour
enquêter
moi j'avais proposé le mois de septembre
parce que je considère qu'il ya trois
ans le temps de la gestion de crise le
temps de la relance économique et
ensuite le temps de l'analyse le sénat a
fait un choix d'avancer cette commission
denquête à partir du moment où cette
commission denquête va s'installer au
mois de juin au sénat
il faut que l'assemblée nationale
coordonne et on est un con concordance
de calendrier entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat
et donc nous installerons très
certainement cette commission denquête
dans le courant du mois de juin les
choses devaient décider à bord de ce
nous avons une mission d'information qui
doit produire un rapport d'étape et
ensuite sur à cette installation de
commission denquête mais mon choix
initial était le mois de septembre
il n'y a pas de course actuellement
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
sur la norme simplement divergences
comment les français peuvent comprendre
que par exemple sénat dans sa commission
denquête au mois de juin et que
l'assemblée nationale le format de
septembre voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
une concordance une convergence mais
maintenant il n'y a pas de course que je
pense qu'on peut tout à fait
complémentaires et c'est normal que les
assemblées se saisissent et qu'une
commission d' enquête sur la non pas
pour faire un tribunal populaire mais
pour pointer la responsabilité politique
les dysfonctionnements et défaillances
qui a eu pendant cette crise damien abad
une question plus politique sur la
droite pendant cette crise sanitaire
beaucoup de personnalités à droite se
sont exprimés et xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse bruno retailleau vous même mais
on a l'impression qu'il ya pas encore
une voie unique pour représenter la
droite dans la période actuelle
comment se passe la reconstruction de
votre famille politique oui vous avez
raison parce que le temps de
l'incarnation et de la présidentielle
viendra il n'est pas encore venu et donc
notre enjeu à nous c'est d'abord il ya
eu plusieurs voix et vous avez quand
même pu noter ça c'est une première qui
a pas eu de voix dissonantes
nous avons chasser en meute nous avons
porté le fer et en tant que président de
groupe à l'assemblée nationale
je ne peux pas être absents on nous dit
oui mais il faut faire attention on est
dans un moment de sanitaires ou il faut
une unité nationale mais ce n'est pas
mettre la poussière sous le tapis
on doit soulever des questions il ya des
interrogations il ya des questions que
se posent les français sur les masques
sur les tests sur la situation d'un aux
ehpad sur la relance économique
qu'est ce que je note je note les
républicains ont été la seule force
politique d'opposition à faire des
propositions nous avons mis un plan de
déconfinement avec 50 propositions sur
la table
72 heures avant le gouvernement aucune
autre opposition n'a fait cela pourquoi
parce que notre rôle c'est d'être une
opposition constructive responsable
active qui dit au gouvernement voilà
nous on est force de proposition
maintenant il faut que vous écoutiez
nous entendent y ait ou pas d'hier matin
midi et soir
oui il faut associer tout le monde il
faut l'unité nationale et quand on
arrive à l'assemblée nationale avoir
toujours ce réflexe qui fait que bien
chaque jour il ya un membre de la
république en marche qui s'en va parce
qu'il ne se sent pas à l'aise dans le
groupe
donc voilà donc nous on a été utile on
était force de proposition et je pense
qu'on a montré une bonne image de la
droite pendant cette crise et justement
pour finir rapidement
l'effritement de la majorité
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale de
la république en marche qui perd sa
majorité absolue comment vous
l'expliquez oui bien je l'expliquent
parce que un groupe politique ce n'est
pas une caserne militaire et donc le
caractère martial ne fonctionne pas ou
si on nous a dit parfois ou celi
république n était pas toujours pareil
vous êtes divisés non on n'est pas
divisé on est libre mais ce que je
souhaite pour tous les groupes
politiques c'est d'être libre
merci beaucoup damien abad d'avoir été
un autre invité politique ce matin sur
le plateau de bonjour chez vous